welcome to this video yet another 15
minute game against nadal the great
Rafael Nadal and from the UK don't they
have their own tennis players to follow
all right so let's see what could I play
I could I could play the Greenfeld I
don't do that normally but let's do do
something else at least in 15 minutes
yes I have some some chances to maybe
find the theoretical moves over the
board Wow g3 that's that's a that's
weird normally you go III yeah the
normal place just see 5 I wonder I
wonder c5 dc5 Queen a 5
c5 dc5 bishop e6 assault songs of course
all that is played with the porn on e3 I
can also take it I could also take it
actually yeah why not have to be honest
why not I mean the normal reaction would
be to play e4 but how does g3 fit into
this now the question is the question is
what to do now I mean there's they are
interesting options now all based on the
fact that his play g3 maybe maybe even
Bishop g4 but also there's be 5c 5 be 59
takes 94-97 hmm it's not clear that i
have a great i even that is not bad but
there's also just be sure deform Bishop
c4 takes a three Queen takes Queen
deform yeah there's no compensation
whatsoever
now yeah this was just good I think one
problem is after ye five that night d 5
is intending to spoil the spawn
structure with night x f4 so I really
don't but now I can really just take
take this pawn and I'm attacking the
bishop oh really lets me exchange her
the Queen's
okay the question is what now should I
go see six here yeah it's gotten I'd be
five moves like that yeah I want to I
want to play a control move to make sure
that nothing terrible happens now if
I've 9595 CD Bishop b5 does not be six
yeah maybe Nyjah for was a good news
yeah well I can maybe still play that
yeah okay I'm a pawn up and he does not
really have anything in particular for
the porn so I need to make a plan think
how to best realize this to to get to
get a win out of it I mean what I'd like
to okay this now changes things
dramatically because I was trying to to
say that I should try to get the dark
squared Bishop Soph but now we just have
an entirely different position after his
he five yeah you came so I think here
what now this is not working at all i
can just take it
yeah I'm uh I'm a piece up check
okay so we had just get off all pieces
in play yeah he just he just basically i
gifted i gifted me the the piece so how
to do that now easiest yeah maybe here
to to get to be to get stuff exchanged
now okay come on so it's four points
against five and he still here he even
has some porn weaknesses III in
particular okay he might go here to this
end so I just blocked that
okay let's all get rocks off it should
should really be enough what now we all
just use the King cannot win without the
king so now probably mmhmm yeah cause
there's more than one way to win we try
to to play it precisely
he does not have many squares take back
requested I don't know why really I
cannot meet him or something and he's
just a piece down I mean
hmm ok I shouldn't tell how kingi do
this wasn't too successful yeah that's
very bad technical plane it still wins
but it wasn't necessary at all to UM to
allow him to even get the porn him
white resign yeah get the H poem yeah
well g3 is just a strange opening you
can of course still try to to hold on
here Bishop g6 every strange but Jim I
don't know if I've is not helping him
because I mean I was just thinking how
to how to get at best these pieces off
if i can get e 52 to block the center
and exchange this bishop i'm i'm
probably just winning but this is not so
easy if he plays it correctly here let's
say it plays a move like that intending
e5 then this is a different different
story I probably go here push it back
and now something like this Bishop f8 to
c5 this is a good plan and this is I'm
looking quite good something like that i
go here get one pair of rooks off
something like that and here maybe an
ice cap Bishop c4 yeah you know he can
he can continue it's not it's not much
fun but the game continues and this is
this is not not helpful at all d 5 is
weak and he has no move really this is
what I was calculating briefly but now
I'm just going in six next and I have a
protected person what I was thinking
after here in fact if you could maybe
play me six but it's not even possible I
can I mean I can take and there is no no
compensation it's two pawns now and
hangs hangs yes no move to to set up
some control over you for any
thing this is a very strong piece yeah
in essence um you you simply cannot play
g3 this is just strange after that this
move is just just not helping at all
yeah the computer points out this funny
move very nice not not there but 94
that's stranger it's not completely
clear by the way this might be a
interesting form ID i think what i did
is simple and good to be honest this is
of course helping me a lot but maybe
here to intend to antenna intending to
play e5 now this might be a try I mean
it still not clear what what this is all
about but II five is an idea white can
certainly fight a fight on in the game
here this is really very questionable
what is not clear so if I need to place
his six but has to like it this is maybe
an alternative directly intending come
on to play five if the the moment is
right yeah okay a groom fought for a
change thanks for watching